joey's actually applauding his good
friend coming by by the way
man you got that is that pretty stellar
there cole hey
this is a great moment guys let's i'm
going to let it live
this is pure respect right here
teammates at hokkaido
he got more respect from both of them
they saw each other in spring training
and
it's fantastic moment that is an
opposing player applauding the guy going
to warm up
dylan bundy is on the mound the
right-hander making his fourth the start
of the season it's more than a strikeout
parading of work dealing with the
visiting texas rangers was in the air a
lot and
i guess when he's right as that one is
in the air
down and in that looked like that split
finger change up
tied him up just enough popped up so
here's the left-handed swinging david
dahl he's their left fielder goes after
the first pitch hits it right into the
shift on the right side that's iglesias
the shortstop who stops it not far from
second and throws him
out there's the pitch he was looking for
earlier
there's that split figure change up the
numbers for kohei orihara we showed you
in the open getting better as he goes
and coming off of
his strongest start so far here in the
u.s shohei ohtani will get ready to
square off against the old friend
two and one and the pitch a swing and a
hard ground ball to first low has it
down to second for one back to first in
time they double up ohtani and he runs
really well seventh pitch of the at-bat
and he got him swinging
so a strike out of trout he got his old
buddy ohtani to hit into a double play
nice inning this is second year with the
angels
and this ball hit out toward right
center field that one gets down
base hit and low will cruise to second
base his second double of the year
and here's willie calhoun
high fly ball right it was a big shift
on already
unbelievable the plays made by fletcher
tagging and
heading into third is low that's how big
and dramatic that shift was
sixth round pick out of oral roberts
university
hit on a line they haven't played
perfectly fletcher there again
he's everywhere david fletcher by a
pitch walk albert pujols will be the
next batter
see if the rangers can turn another
double play albert swings hits a ground
ball to the second baseman solac
he feeds izzy onto first an easy double
play pool's barely running
garcia playing in his seventh game is
batting 200
and bundy's 2-1 in the air
out to right field that could be trouble
walsh is back
gone a solo
shot for adolesce garcia to start the
third
take a look here trying to go down and
in instead the pitch is up and away
and 92 miles an hour you're not going to
get it past the big strong
garcia really nice looking swing to see
this kind of power
here's the o2 and he was fooled on that
one
waves and misses runner goes breaking
ball that's strike three
the classic hammer sends him back to
that dugout
into the glove tries again here at one
and two
and a swing and a miss on a pitch that
kind of had to bottom fall out of it
again either the change up for the uh
splitter
seventh pitch of the at-bat and randhifa
swings and misses strike three
third strikeout for arihara
nate lowe jumps on a breaking ball big
time topspin
into the glove of jarrett walsh
there's two strikes on solac and he came
right back with another slider and the
same result
swings and misses it struck him out and
that's out number
two one and two the count as he deals
with the big time shift
wrecking ball over the top defense not
needed that time very strong
and that brings up shohei ohtani here's
the 2-1
that ball is hit high and deep out into
center field
garcia ranging back on the track at the
wall he leaps and he makes the catch
go ahead with yourself and the reactions
off-speed pitch
a little bad toss and garcia's got
something for you shohei
calm reaction not today
working quickly to garcia and he left
that one up a little bit
and it is belted down into the corner
and then up into the seats
for the automatic double so garcia
the home run the double the great catch
at the wall
i'm not even halfway through the ball
game and with two outs it brings up
david dahl got him with a fast ball
press and down goes dahl
and so far so good for kohei arihara
the 02 to upton there's a swing and a
miss
fifth strike out tonight there's a
really good look at that
split finger how about the depth i mean
out of the picture at that point
and with two on and nobody out nick
solac is coming up
bundy checks second gala with the lead
there pitch to nick in the ground ball
right side it's through the hole a base
hit
the rangers have them loaded and now the
ball is bobbled and gala will come in
and score
so that's a single for solac no run
batted in
an error on jared walsh in right and
it's two to nothing texas
here is willie calhoun first and second
nobody out
hated by the error as well and willie
goes up after one and shoots it into
left field
around third base low he heads to the
plate
into third base safely is solac and
willie calhoun drives in another run
it's three nothing rangers enjoy the
lifestyle
this one left up a little bit trevino
just
missed it deep out to left field it'll
be enough to get solac
to the plate and calhoun heading to
third he advances as well
so a sacked fly makes it four nothing
here comes adoles who has a home run to
a right center and a
double down the left field line a 2-0
and a ground ball hit off the glove of
rangifo at third in the left
that will score calhoun make it five
nothing rangers
so one out in the inning and the seventh
batter brock holt is at the plate
here it comes to holt and a line drive
to left center field base hit
garcia racing around third digging for
the plate here's the throw by trout
and he scores standing up and so hulk
drives in a run
it's six nothing rangers
well things are going pretty smoothly so
far tonight for
kohei arihara and a swing and a miss
that's going to be it's five and two
thirds six strikeouts tonight new season
slash career high for ariara
upton lined out hard back in the second
inning here's the one two
this is hit pretty well in a right
center field that ball is traveling out
in right center field and
that ball is going to get out in right
center field
right center field for a jay up j up
going
up down funk on that one the other way
the 2-1
pujols line drive base it into left
field
like a kid out there walsh
come on down 2 105
rbis kurt suzuki oh for two
look at the huge jump a double steal
ha ha look at albert out there in third
clap in his hands
if you can make him pay to the right
side he made him pay
iglesias stops at 30 and it holds so
hard they can only played one
to the backstop it goes here comes
iglesias
it's 6-4 ian kennedy on here in the
night
overall 70 strikes 80 first pitch
strikes
on first and third winning run now
strides to the plate
to finish it off here the o2 bouncer
right side of the infield solac
is there and he gets it done randhifa
retired
and the rangers hold on for a 6-4
opening win in this huge series